Tyler congratulations on making it this
far but for the rest of this final level
we're going to change things up the
judges are in charge it's our turn to
Make Some Noise we're going to pick
everything from the weapon you have to
build the materials you have to build it
with the tests it's all on us
but our first decision is which judge
you'll be going up against that judge is
Ben Abbott
Ben what's up Tyler
all right gentlemen you've got your work
cut out for you you're going to have
eight hours to finish a blade that I
picked from our forged and fire Vault
that weapon is
the Cinque DEA
and Smith to make your weapon you're
going to be using this
stacks of 1095 5920 high carbon steel
your job is going to alternate these
stacks and make a pattern for me not
just a random pattern you're going to do
a twist and stack method you're going to
take a minimum of three of these bars
twist them restack them and use that
material to forge your blade
all right gentlemen time starts now
part of me showing my best work is
bringing my a game with Damascus I'm
known for making Damascus that's all I
do I cut steel I stack it and I Forge it
look at that Damascus pattern it's
beautiful it looks good beautiful work
I'm gonna have to one longer piece in
the center three pieces on each side of
that and then a nice little short piece
for my puddle and I still have a nice
piece left over from a guard
I know we need only three bullets for
the sword but I'm here to beat that so
I'm gonna bring my hey game in my style
and we're gonna have to see what comes
out on top
the more twists the better and as long
as I get a nice tight pattern I feel
good about it I'm gonna twist half of
the bars clockwise half of them
counterclockwise that'll give that star
pattern as opposed to three twists going
the same direction that's good
I've been on both sides of this I've
been a man Swinging The Sword and I've
been the man making the sword and making
the sword is a lot harder eight hours in
this Forge doing this kind of
competition is at the limits of my
abilities for sure
I hope you guys like swinging boat
anchors
go Ben quenched
and we got a question yeah
I'm hoping that my sword doesn't blow
into pieces when I pull it out
and sticking together and she's rock
hard the Fullers are going to open that
pattern up change it a bit but also I
hope they really use the Fullers wisely
and make that chickadea light it doesn't
have to be heavy
huh
we've got Ben over here finishing up
he's got to sharpen his blade and form
the handle
I'm competing for a charity called Black
Horse Forge which is a small non-profit
that gives free blacksmithing classes to
Military and First Responders and their
families so I'm going to try my best to
win this thing
it is in the panic mode right yeah yeah
everybody's moving fast
five four three two one good job guys
where'd it go guys where'd it go
[Applause]
there's a bug lean on that shutter
all right blade Smith welcome to the
Keel test it's time to make some noise
with your weapons to find out what kind
of lethal damage your chicadeas will do
I'm going to deliver slashes and thrust
on this ballistics dummy bendy up first
you ready for this yes I am
oh
I think he's got much to say now no
all right Ben let's talk about your
weapon here the foolish you have there
are wide enough to be able to lighten
the blade tip here is acute enough for
deep thrust into this ballistics dummy
and at the same time in chopping that
jaw off it shows that it is a sharp and
strong blade overall it will kill yes
brother
all right Tyler your turn sir you ready
let's do this
right time to talk about your cigarette
here the chops go into the biscuit
zombie and into the bone and breaks the
bone in there at the same time it's cut
and the thrust in there is deep it
penetrates nice and cuts on the way out
more importantly sir your weapon here
we'll kill thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test now I'm going to take your
weapons and smash them again and again
into these steel wind chimes
well let's ring a bell what do you say
Ben I was ready for wooden wind chimes
[Music]
[Music]
Ben this blade is still razor sharp the
only blade issue is the teeniest
deformation right there where my finger
is other than that blade is intact solid
is when I started
well done thank you very much
Tyler your turn let's do it
[Music]
oh
it's a man
foreign
this is a tough test banging a sword
against metal wind chimes
and yours held up beautifully nicely
done but it's heavy I would love to have
seen these Fullers be a lot deeper
there's so much mass still in this blade
but it's definitely a strong weapon well
done thank you
all right blade Smiths now it's time for
the sharpness test been here first you
ready to go cut some stuff Jay
foreign
nice job Ben thank you balance is very
nice
you know something that looks this huge
it's got a good feel to it and it cut
fine
good job thank you very much all right
Tyler you're up you're ready to go yeah
let's do this
they gotta let me break something and
make me happy
Tyler
nice job thank you this sucker is sharp
there's no drags no stutters at all
overall
good job thank you
bladesmiths or should I say two-time
Fortune fire Champions congratulations
that was a well-fought round and you
guys did an amazing job but there could
only be one winner
[Music]
Ben Abbott
and congratulations for winning this
Pete the judges competition and this
also comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars to your favorite charity which
is like horse Forge great cause right
there
Tyler you did a great job putting that
steel together and making a sword that's
a devastating cutter it's just the
extreme weight and the lack of finish
that came along with your blade really
just put it into second place that's why
we're letting you go understandable
I didn't lose this competition to bed he
just outsmith me
but for me it wasn't a loss I kicked ass
and I made awesome blades throughout
this whole challenge in the end Ben just
made a better blade than mine I'm proud
of myself pleasure man
competing against Tyler was very
difficult but I'm still undefeated and
it's incredible so anybody out there
that feels like they want to come up and
compete against us judges we're ready
for you bring it on